- Hello, YouTubiverse.
Neil DeGrasse Tyson here,
your personal astrophysicist.
I just got off of a video call
with the International Space Station,
a live conversation with
the two astronauts there.
And who were they?
We had Jessica Meir and Christina Koch.
They've spacewalked together recently
and got a little bit of
that overview effect.
So, in this brief call
we talked about food,
politics, Mars, and also,
I had to end with a comment
about what it's like to clean up vomit
in case that happens.
Check it out.
(upbeat music)
- [Mission Control]
Station, this is Houston.
Are you ready for the event?
- Houston, this is Station.
We're ready for the event.
- [Mission Control] "StarTalk",
this is Mission Control Houston,
please call Station for a voice check.
- Station, this is Neil DeGrasse Tyson
with "StarTalk Radio".
How do you hear me?
- Hello, Neil, we have you loud and clear.
How do you hear us?
- Excellent, excellent.
Let's do this.
It's great to have this time with you.
I think they only gave us 20 minutes,
that must be when you're in
this part of the hemisphere,
so I'm gonna try to squeeze
in a whole lotta questions.
Both of you, of course,
are scientifically trained,
and I'm just wondering,
what kind of science
and engineering tasks or
projects, or experiments,
have you been conducting
while you've been up there
on the International Space Station.
- Well, we have really been involved
in every type of science.
So far, I have been up
here for about two months.
I have been involved in an experiment
growing Mizuna lettuce,
that's actually located
right here next to us.
You can see the two different
light wavelengths here,
we've got a red and a blue wavelength,
evaluating light quality and fertilizer.
I've been involved in a variety
of physiological and medical studies.
We have done experiments looking
at protein crystal growth,
evaluating having potential
for future pharmaceuticals
for various drugs for disease states.
We have been involved
in ultrasound studies,
looking at different physiological
aspects like blood flow,
and how that changes in micro-gravity.
Really, any type of science, you name it.
Combustion experiments, for example,
we have a combustion rack,
even flames, of course, burn
differently in micro-gravity.
So, a little bit of a
sampling of everything,
and I think that's what keeps
our jobs so interesting,
is that it's not just,
for example, my particular
field of expertise,
it's really all the aspects of science.
- Combustion experiments.
(laughing)
That doesn't sound safe.
I assume there are fire
extinguishers all around Station.
- That is true, there
are fire extinguishers
all around Station, but we do hope
to never have to use them on
our Combustion Integrated Rack,
the Scientific Payload Rack
where we do combustion experiments.
They're in a chamber that, obviously,
has all the safety requirements needed.
The interesting thing about
that type of experiment
is how differently flames
burn in micro-gravity
because there's no convection
to bring the hot air up
and create the shape of
flame that we're used to,
for example, on a candle.
It's a very different environment,
and it allows us to get to some
of the fundamental properties
of flames, and turns out,
it's a lot more complicated
than you might think,
and the results of those experiments
not only affect and benefit life on Earth
in terms of fuel efficiency and whatnot,
but it also informs
things like flammability
for products for use in
space and space travel.
- One of my favorite experiments
is when you burn a candle
in zero-G, and then it just exhausts
all the oxygen in its environment.
And you're right, like you said,
without the convection, a
candle will self-extinguish,
I guess you see this when
you do these experiments.
- Yup, that's absolutely true,
and we see other really
interesting evidence
of lack of convection here.
Like for example, when
we take our food packets
out of our little oven
and set them on the table
to cool off, it takes a lot longer
unless we actually put them in an airpath.
(laughing)
- So much we take for
granted here on Earth
just by living in one-G.
I have a quick question.
I gotta settle this once and for all.
Every bit of physics I know
tells me you are in
free fall towards Earth,
which renders all of you weightless,
and everything in the
International Space Station,
so I would call that zero-G.
Where does NASA come
off calling it micro-G?
- Yep, that's a great question.
I think the idea is just the concept
that everything that has mass
also produces a gravitational field,
so we might be wrong to call it zero-G
just because, obviously,
everything around me
does have a non zero gravitational force
associated with it.
- Okay, but they're very
tiny gravitational forces,
so we could just as easily
call it nano-G, couldn't we?
- Nano, pico, you know.
I'm not sure they
actually calculated that,
but it's definitely true
that we are all in free fall
around the planet, and we are experiencing
the gravitational pull of Earth,
which is actually what keeps
us in orbit around Earth.
So, you could also look at it that way,
that we're not zero-G in that sense,
but the free fall aspect of zero-gravity,
I'd say we're in it.
Did we land ourselves on the
right side of your argument?
(laughing)
- I'm gonna look up all my metric prefixes
and see which one actually applies
to how much gravity each one
of you have on each other,
and I'll get back to you on that.
- Yeah, and I think the other difference
is that we are constantly disturbing
this micro-gravity environment.
So, any time we input a motion,
if we're exercising on the treadmill,
or the cycle ergometer on ARED,
we're disturbing that
pure zero-gravity force
that maybe an experiment desires
just by our human presence.
So, we're still disturbing
that all the time.
- So, let's talk about food.
There're different segments
of the International Space Station
representing different
countries who participate.
And so, do each of you
trade food with each other
when you get bored with
your meatloaf, or something?
(laughing) I'm just curious
how much food exchange goes on
on the International Space Station.
- So, NASA has a food
lab, which you may know,
and they develop most of a majority
of the food that we, as
American astronauts, eat.
But the Russians also have a food lab,
and we are actually allowed to choose
a certain number of our food allocation
from the Russian food system.
So, both Christina and I like
exotic and different foods,
and so we went with a maximum
majority of Russian food
that we could add.
We also have some foods developed
by European Space Agency
that we can add to that mix,
and we have a European Space
Agency astronaut up here,
so we get to sample a
little bit more of that
because he has a little bit
more of that than other people.
My goals was actually to fly
with a Japanese astronaut
because I love Japanese food,
and I really wanted some of that.
But unfortunately, we
don't have any of that
up here right now.
But we do tend to share,
the Russians will actually
bring other things down to us,
and we'll trade favorites back and forth.
So, I think variety is very
important for us up here,
even more important
than people would think.
People that don't even care so much
about food on the ground do tend to,
in a long duration mission,
feel the need to have
some more variety and make a difference
in terms of just that boredom
that develops otherwise.
- I've eaten in restaurants
in both Italy and in France,
and I'm guessing the French
and Italians have no interest
in trading food with
anybody else. (laughing)
- Well, our Italian is pretty generous.
I think one of the
highlights on the food system
is the lettuce experiment
that we talked about earlier.
Part of that, instead of
sending all of the samples
down to be analyzed by the ground team,
we actually get to harvest
and eat the lettuce.
So, we've had two harvests now
where we get this fresh
supplement lettuce to our diet,
and that's a real treat.
And we'll have another harvest
the day before we celebrate Thanksgiving,
so we're looking forward to that.
- So, I've been curious about that.
For longterm space travel,
obviously there'll be some expectation
that you grow your own food.
How close are we to growing
all of your own food
without requiring supply chains
either to and from the Space Station,
or to and from Mars, if that's
our ultimate destination.
- Absolutely, great question.
I think that right now we're at a place
where we're learning the best ways
that we can grow things in space,
but where we're really looking to go
is to develop systems that are one,
closed loop systems, so a
system where we're using
waste products from various sources
and feeding those in to the
actual plant development.
And that can include our
carbon dioxide cycle,
our oxygen cycle, and our water cycle,
and we actually have some
really neat life support systems
onboard right now that are testing
some of those technologies.
Another aspect of the food system
that really has to grow
would be incorporating proteins.
Right now we have lettuce as
our main crop that we've grown,
and we've grown different things up there,
they've grown flowers, we're looking into
starting into vegetables and fruits,
but incorporating protein
sources like peanuts,
or maybe legumes, I
think, is a next big leap.
And we're not quite there yet,
as Jessica mentioned, we've had salad,
and we've joked sometimes
that the caloric intake
that we've used so far in growing it
might be a little bit more
than what we end up consuming.
But obviously the techniques
are what's important,
and proving out the systems
and the operational concept.
- I'm guessing that you're not gonna,
any time soon, start
traveling with farm animals.
So, likely all of your protein will come
from plant-based sources,
which would mean the
future space exploration
would be vegetarian, that's
what that sounds like.
- Maybe, we're not sure.
We also do have some other devices
that are pretty exciting
up here right now.
We have one facility called
the BioFabrication Facility,
which is actually, the
goal of that is to grow
human organs in space.
Now, that's of course not
for food or consumption,
that is to contribute to the deficit
of organ for transplant
operations on the ground.
By any kinds of efforts on the ground,
when you are trying to
produce these tissues
and make these bioartificial tissues,
there are some problems
with the support structure for these.
And so, the theory is, in micro-gravity,
we won't have that problem
with the support structure,
so we can better grow these
bioartificial tissues,
and then turn them into complete organs.
Going a little bit along
with that with 3D printing,
we have other 3D printers up here
to make other pieces of hardware.
The Russians also recently
tested some animal cells,
so, some animal protein cells
to see whether or not
they could 3D print meat.
So, there are some
experiments that are trending
in that direction as well.
- I don't know why I didn't
think of that, of course.
If you can lab grow
proteins, meat proteins,
then you never needed the
animal in the first place,
and then there's another
source of protein for you.
So, excellent.
I'm just curious, can you imagine
a totally self-sustaining place on Mars?
How soon do you think we can have
a self-sustaining Mars colony?
Are we counting that in
decades now, not just years?
Because we know you can get water on Mars,
and fuel, maybe, rocket fuel.
If you could just elaborate a little bit
about what's there on Mars already
versus what, at least initially,
we've gotta bring there
to help you survive.
- Sure.
Looking at the current outlook
in some of NASA's longterm goals,
talking about going back
to the moon in the 2020s,
and then back to the Mars
in maybe the late 2030s,
so that would be sort
of, an initial visit,
some of the baseline design concepts
would be for a 15-month
mission, a three-year mission,
somewhere in that range.
To do a sustainable mission,
I think we are definitely talking decades,
but I think it's important
to have the longterm goal always in mind.
I've never been someone
that has been a fan
of terra transforming a planet
to make it more Earth-like.
I think that the excitement
of going to a different planet
would be utilizing the in
situ resources that are there.
So, I would see something
like a sustainable Mars establishment,
to me, would always require
some type of resupply,
and even if that's just to
make it livable and habitable
in terms of what humans think
of as habitable and livable,
I think is the important thing.
But using the in situ resources as well.
- Yeah, I think the...
If you were to drive
across the United States,
there's basically a supply
chain there already for you.
You can stop at the
Quik Mart and get food,
and something already
brought the food there
for you to then eat before you arrived.
So, maybe the idea of supply chains
shouldn't be viewed as
something so foreign,
because we actually thrive on that here.
I'm curious about the future of robotics,
and artificial intelligence.
There's a whole camp, I'm not in this camp
that I'm about to describe,
that would say "Do all space
exploration with robots.
"Do all space exploration with robots,
"and then you don't even need the people,
"you don't have to bring the robot back,
"so they're cheaper."
And so, I know you guys are astronauts,
but I'm just wondering
what kind of thinking
you put into the idea of robot
astronauts for the future.
- Yeah, I've heard a lot of
people debate that as well.
Maybe "Why do we even care
about human space flight,
"maybe we can do it all with robotics,"
and I think the answer
isn't one or the other,
it's really a blend.
And the two can be complementary
for different purposes
and for different reasons.
We, of course, have had a lot of success
sending satellites, and sending
rovers and other spacecraft.
There have been several rovers on Mars
that have provided a
wealth of data already,
and we haven't been there yet as people,
so that's showing us that
there are some things
that we've already been able to do
with these robotic spacecraft
that we haven't done yet with humans.
But of course, if you
look at the other side,
you can look at the statistics
and what these rovers
were able to accomplish
in terms of their exploration,
sending the data back,
then being controlled
by people on the ground
and having that relayed back
if they found something off-nominal,
or something where they wanted
to go a different direction,
that actually ends up taking months.
And the statistic that I've seen,
is that what a rover can
do in months or even years,
astronauts can do in minutes or hours
just because we have the capability
to problem solve directly real-time,
and then redirect those necessary.
So, I would see the
future as involving both.
I would love to go on a
mission with robots as well.
I mean, we could bring
humans and robots together.
- So, just to be clear,
your phrase off-nominal
really to the rest of us just means weird.
(laughing)
- That's right.
Sorry for the vernacular there.
Anything unexpected.
What wasn't programmed in, for example,
but the people on the ground
as to what the course would be.
If we saw something more interesting,
or more scientifically
valuable in another direction
we could redirect ourselves,
whereas the rover might be
programmed in one direction
and would miss out on an
opportunity like that.
- Promise me, if any of you go to Mars
and you see something off-nominal
that you'll just say to NASA,
"I see something weird," okay?
I want you to promise me
here and now. (laughing)
- I'm not sure we can make
those kinda promises to you.
(laughing)
- A quick question just about politics.
You guys have spacewalked,
as so many visitors to the Station do,
you spacewalk together, and you see Earth.
And that Earth does not have
color-coded boundaries of countries.
And so, surely you get the newsfeed
in who's in conflict with whom,
and who's spying, and who's fighting.
This overview effect, which
so much is written about,
how do you see the future
of politics in space
versus what's going on down here on Earth?
Can space be something that leads
all peace movements on Earth?
How much thinking have you guys done about
the role that space can
play in the future of this?
- We both have been fortunate enough
to experience that overview effect,
and I do think that it has the option
of improving the world in
the way that you talk about.
One thing that we've learned is that,
we get the question a lot,
do politics on Earth inform the way
that you do your job on here
with the international community?
And I like to flip it around and say
that the way we do things up here
actually can inform our politics on Earth.
So, I think we do see this as an example
of how we can work together
for the greater good,
for greater humanity, and the fact
that we are more alike
than we are different,
and we all have the
same goals at our roots.
- And I think a specific example of that,
both Christina and I launched here
to the International Space
Station having trained
a majority of our training in Russia,
at the Gagarin Cosmonaut Training Center
with the Russian Space Agency,
we launched on a Russian
space vehicle to get here,
and for many years now,
that has been our only means
of coming to space.
And so, that is something that,
especially right now given
the current political climate,
may be surprising to some people,
but for us all up here,
we're working together
as one crew and as one team.
And I think that space has this ability
to actually transcend
some of those problems
that we're having on the ground.
So, hopefully we here on the
International Space Station
can provide and maybe serve
as an exemplary role model
for people on the ground as well.
Jokingly, I've often said maybe a lot
of our world leaders need to come up here
and experience that overview
effect for themselves
to really understand what it means.
- That shouldn't be a joke,
that should be real. (laughing)
time for just a couple more questions,
I just wanna have some fun questions.
So, one of them is, I've
sometimes been criticized
for commenting on the science of movies,
and in the movie "Gravity"
Sandra Bullock's bangs
always pointed down, and
I'm looking at your hair now
doing it's thing, doing it's zero-G thing,
and so, I'm just curious.
I don't know, I guess
that wasn't a question,
I just wanna tell everyone,
look at your hair in space,
in zero-G, the hair does
not know which way down is.
(laughing) There you go.
There you go.
- Yeah.
Yep, that's absolutely true.
I think our special effects
are a little bit better up here, maybe,
than in the movie "Gravity".
But for me, I was really surprised
that not only did my
hair not float sideways,
it actually just goes straight up,
which makes sense in retrospect,
but you don't really
even expect that much.
- But of course, there
is no sideways in space
if there is not down or up.
So, one final question.
Being in zero-G, presumably,
would make your stomach
queasy at some point,
certainly initially, so, I am
certain at least one of you
have thrown up in the space
of the Space Station before.
So, how do you clean that up
if it's just scattering everywhere?
- Actually, both of us have
been extremely fortunate,
and neither of us have had the opportunity
to experience that.
Not that it couldn't still
happen for some other reason,
but I think we're probably
past that risk period.
But we do, of course, prepare for it
because it does strike many astronauts,
and you don't really
know who it's gonna be.
You can't really prepare for it.
So, we have special motion sickness bags
that we fly with us in the spacecraft,
and that we have up here
in case anyone needs them.
Because like you said, of course,
it's going to be very
difficult to contain.
And I remember seeing that in person
on several flights that I
did on parabolic flights
on what we call the Vomit Comet,
and observing some people that tried
to utilize the bags and missed,
and that makes for quite a mess,
especially with a plane
because then you experience the two-G.
But we are equipped,
really, to deal with that
and to deal with any kind of
medical situations up here
with our training and all of our supplies
on the Space Station.
- Well, excellent, guys.
Thanks for taking the
time for "StarTalk Radio",
and we got you on video as well.
And so, very much appreciated this.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you, Neil.
It was our pleasure.
- [Mission Control] Station,
this is Houston ACR,
that concludes our event
as we countdown to 20 continuous years
of humans living and working
on the International Space Station.
(upbeat music)